the appearance of hammer space and
Spider-Man across the spiderverse comes
and goes very quickly but the special
ability is a history that goes back
nearly a century want to know what it
really means then consider it Hammer
Time
Spider-Man across the spider verse is
one of those rare sequels that exceeds
all expectations given Parts how it
Embraces the dazzling combination of
Animation Styles pioneered by its
predecessor while the film is certainly
a visual Feast for Webheads and
newcomers alike it's yet another
passionate love letter to the animated
medium and the worlds that Marvel has
built in their Comics there's so many
deep cut references that they'll make
your head spin and one of those
references is to the concept of hammer
space for spider-verse fans Hammer space
is mostly associated with John mulaney's
cartoony porkish web Slinger spider ham
hailing from an earth inhabited by
Looney Tunes like anthropomorphic
animals spider hammers repeatedly shown
to be able to produce impossible objects
from baffling places no matter what
Universe he's in he's able to stop the
Scorpion by hitting him with an anvil
Roadrunner style and just before he
returns for his Homeworld he presents
Miles Morales with a special Hammer I
want you to have this it'll fit in your
pocket
That's all folks is he allowed to say
that legally
spider Ham's passing line into the
spider-verse was an earlier reference
for a power that his name dropped by
Miguel O'Hara drawing his fight with the
da Vinci vulture at the beginning of
across the spider-verse though it might
seem like a clever invention made
specifically for spider ham or even the
Marvel Universe At Large it's actually a
decades-old term coined for a
long-standing animation Trope the exact
origins of hammer space on are precisely
known but some well-founded theories
have been offered over the years the
concept itself has widely attributed to
the Golden Age of Animation which began
at the end of the 1920s with companies
like Warner Brothers Hannah Barbera and
Walt Disney Studios rising to prominence
Hammer space wasn't written as a
distinct power in superhero media until
later on some fans believe that the
first instances of characters pointing
out their own ability to produce objects
out of nowhere come from Japanese
animation and Comics others theorize
that the role-playing game Dungeons and
Dragons was the first to establish a
convenient mechanic as a magical ability
to the bag of whole building however the
character of Mary Poppins was created
well before Dungeons and Dragons and she
carries a carpet bag that's able to hold
seemingly infinite contents regardless a
warehammer space came from it has long
been a part of the Marvel universe as an
established superpower although its use
as often in Omar's animation any
narrative explanation for its existence
so far is unique to the comics in the
Marvel universe spider-ham is one of
several characters capable of accessing
Hammer space another prominent one being
the clownish anti-hero slapstick no
matter which villain or hero is using
hammer space its existence is usually
explained as being some sort of pocket
Dimension a pocket Dimension at least in
Marvel Comics is a space outside the
normal universe that is drastically
smaller than any of the alternate Earths
we've seen one popular example of a
pocket Dimension can be seen at the end
of the Disney plus series what if in
which variants of arnim Zola and
killmonger are trapped in a tiny
Dimension while they wrestle over the
Infinity Stones seemingly for eternity
for spider ham specifically it's likely
that he has access to a small pocket
Dimension through a portal in well his
pocket one can imagine that there must
be a massive arsenal of cartoonish
weapons and objects stored for future
battles we'll certainly get to see more
of hammer space when spider Hammer makes
his return in Spider-Man and Beyond the
spider verse in 2024
foreign